bientôt on sait squeeze aujourd'hui on
se retrouve pour une vidéo sur lotus
rift autrement appelés no destructeur de
coupe de cheveux vous allez très vite
comprendre pourquoi
voilà maintenant j'ai deux coupes de
cheveux une de l'hémisphère gauche de
mon crâne et une bonne hémisphère droit
ok c'est parti c'est à tous par fois que
je fais un jeu illustre if moi j'ai
juste fait la démo un peu un peu pété
dans une maison là où il ya absolument
rien tu crois que tu as une vidéo
falloir que non pas du tout et dans un
truc un casque virtuel c'est peut-être
mettre le casque et à du son à huy ya
quand même le son du train à quai c'est
que ça reste que j'ai des saints non aux
géantes et on en forme de croix a trait
à la mode un téton brûlé un ok donc là
on est parti pour une attraction un peu
un peu space 1
j'ai pas l'impression que l'oreille est
trop petit par rapport aux wagons
personnellement je dépasse carrément
dans le vide
c'est carrément chelou donc c'est là
c'est aussi sur les sortes de poils
enfin bref on arrête de rigoler oh j'ai
l'impression d'y être je dois passer
pour un [ __ ] de psychopathe
qu'est ce que cette attraction fait dans
le manoir de dracula oh merde tu avais
je bouge tout seul quand on siège comme
un gros con tu fais attention tu as une
fracture du genou et wallet mais ça fait
carrément vomir quoi auquel amusement
assez la fin l'avantagé oculus et que tu
n'as pas besoin de faire la queue
ça c'est un retard tout de suite
d'accord allez braquer un bouche-trou
j'ai carrément la gerbe donc la maman
est dans un jeu en incarnant turquie
matinée tu vois laurent larivière nos
positions on a reposé sur six mots voilà
heureusement que ces gens ne sont pas
des simples cartons salut à toi
attendait alors vous pouvez aussi
emmener votre kiosque en vacances vu la
taille qu'il fait ça cache bien soleil
une sorte de casque est technologique
on est maintenant sur don't let go et on
a un t-shirt carrément chinois est
carrément style est prêt et space to
start à temps voilà je t'en prie old
boys contrôler ce don hachey fourre tout
ok d'accord donc je vais garder le
bouton contrôle a à portée de doigts ok
c'est parti alors game over one ok faut
rester appuyé sur les deux boutons
watford caisse et ça a été je suis
allergique
j'avais de la chance que j'ai pas mis de
la crème anti moustiques
ce n'est donc pas la bouche quoi je peux
porter la mémoire ces deux buts à deux
boutons à ça va mieux alors dans
l'oreille dégage dégage watts salue sa
technique que veux tu sais tu as vite
peut-être qu est-ce qui fait très bien
d'accord donc ça ça voulait dire va te
faire [ __ ] en langage des dinosaures
je crois à l'est et ferme la porte de
mon bureau
voilà un j'aime bien avoir l'autorité un
peu comme la porte 10 watts
il a dit ça fait peut-être pas assez
peur pour toi
il a parlé d'araignée géante non warning
araignée allez c'est pas ça non plus le
[ __ ] c'est vraiment j'aimais bien les
couteaux 1 c'était pas mal à louga
personnes étaient souvent bon j'ai
compris que je t'aimais bien le sens -
garnier arrête de laisser mes cheveux
s'il te plaît le pet à l'hectare céder
ses titres miniers est ce que c'est la
ouate howey au hockey c'est le décès on
jouera l'oculus ok qu'est ce qui se
passe on fait petite danse doit pas
compter les heures
à leur tour de l'art y est et autour de
l'araignée des cheveux oh non non je
sors ton la mer va se rallumer on va
voir une sorte de mr bean en trois
classes et j'avais raison
j'ai gagné mais mettra vraiment fait
laisse moi essayer encore quelque chose
what je sais que ça salut victory
c'était génial
en plus j'ai pas du tout ils peur donc
je suis vraiment vraiment content
d'ailleurs le bombardant la région s'est
déjà fin de cette vidéo très très courte
1 c'est la première fois que j'utilisais
le coeur du strip s'ils ont des vrais
jouets page sur juste la démo de base et
je voulais faire ça en votre compagnie
as tu voyais mes réactions et que vous
voyez l'homme viril que je suis c'est
bon c'est bon
j'espère si vous a plu si c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à dire dans les
commentaires à aimer la vidéo ça me fera
plaisir encore une fois on se retrouve
bientôt dans une nouvelle vidéo
peut-être sur le cumul sur un jeu
d'horreur que ça fait longtemps que
c'est une bonne occasion pour se
retrouver sur ce sujet philippe ans ou
peut-être pas peut-être qu'il va tomber
en panne avant où je sens où tu te rends
pas où tu au titre au casque à eilat ya
de monde plus
[Musique]